(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Vamos falar agora sobre o termo nua propriedade
que aparece em alguns editais de leilão.
O que é a nua propriedade?
A nua propriedade, ela decorre do uso fruto.
O uso fruto é um direito real de
usar e fluir de coisa alheia.
No uso fruto, nós temos de um lado
o nu proprietário, que é o proprietário do
imóvel que vai transferir as faculdades de usar
e fluir do bem para outra pessoa, e
de outro lado o uso frutuário, que é
a pessoa que vai receber a posse do
bem com a faculdade de usar e fluir
do bem.
O uso fruto, ele pode ser temporário ou
vitalício.
Vamos aqui a um exemplo.
Qual é o exemplo mais clássico de alguém
construir uso fruto para alguém?
Vamos aqui pensar em um casal de idosos
que tem um apartamento.
Esse casal de idosos, ele pode pensar no
seguinte, nós queremos evitar brigas que possam acontecer
com os nossos filhos quando a gente morrer
pela herança, ou até mesmo nós queremos adiantar
o lado dos nossos filhos, para que eles
não tenham que abrir um processo de inventário
e para que eles não tenham que pagar
o imposto sobre transmissão dos nossos bens.
Então, nós dois, como um casal de idosos,
vamos fazer doação dos nossos bens para os
nossos filhos, vamos fazer essa doação em vida.
Mas a gente, como casal, quer se resguardar
de que, enquanto estivermos vivos, vamos ter direitos
a usar e fluir do bem como a
gente quiser, daquele bem imóvel.
O que significa fluir de um bem imóvel?
Significa que você pode ter rendimentos com aquele
bem, ou seja, você pode alugar aquele bem
e gerar um rendimento mensal.
Quando existe um uso fruto, quem vai receber
esse rendimento mensal desse aluguel é o uso
frutuário, que não é o proprietário do bem,
afinal, o proprietário do bem, como a gente
acabou de ver, é o nu proprietário.
O uso frutuário é quem tem o direito
de usar, gozar e fluir da coisa, fluir
a barca, inclusive receber aluguéis sobre aquele imóvel.
Então, voltando, esse casal vai fazer uma doação
em vida para os filhos, para que os
filhos não briguem posteriormente após a morte deles,
ou até mesmo para livrar os filhos de
ter que fazer um inventário e recolher um
imposto sobre transmissão de herança.
Então, esse casal vai fazer uma doação e
para se resguardar de que eles vão poder
usar plenamente aquele bem, ou até mesmo alugar,
caso seja da vontade deles, eles vão construir
um uso fruto.
Então, ocorre a doação e logo depois ocorre
o uso fruto.
Esse casal doou para os filhos, os filhos
passam a ser proprietário daquele bem imóvel então,
e os filhos vão fazer esse uso fruto
para os pais, para que os pais possam
ter, enquanto estão vivos, a garantia de que
vão fazer o que quiser com aquele bem,
o que melhor entenderem como usar ou até
alugar aquele bem.
A doação e o uso fruto tem que
necessariamente ser registrado na matrícula do imóvel.
Como eu falei anteriormente, a gente tem o
uso fruto temporário e o uso fruto vitalício.
Nesse exemplo aqui do casal de idosos que
a gente botou, se o uso fruto fosse
vitalício, esse uso fruto existiria, até o momento
da morte desse casal, das duas pessoas que
compõem esse casal.
Afinal, o uso fruto foi constituído em benefício
das duas pessoas desse casal.
Agora vamos supor, quando ocorreu a doação desse
casal para os filhos, os filhos passaram a
ser os proprietários daquele imóvel, e nada impede
que um desses filhos esteja devendo para outras
pessoas, e que essas outras pessoas ingressem no
poder judiciário para receber o que elas têm
direito.
Então vamos lá, o poder judiciário vai agir,
ao final daquele processo vai condenar um desses
filhos a pagar a quantia que ele está
devendo para alguém, e na hora de fazer
o levantamento daqueles bens, o judiciário percebe que
esse filho que recebeu aquele bem em doação,
e que está com o uso fruto para
os seus pais, ele só tem uma fração
daquele bem.
E o que o judiciário vai fazer?
O judiciário vai leiloar a nua propriedade, porque
afinal de contas esse filho, ele é proprietário
daquele bem, mas ele ainda não tem o
direito de ter posse daquele bem, ele só
vai ter a posse daquele bem quando seus
pais morrerem, porque quando seus pais morrerem vai
acabar o uso fruto, então ele vai ter
a propriedade plena.
O judiciário então, ele coloca a nua propriedade
em leilão.
E qual é a consequência do judiciário colocar
a nua propriedade em leilão?
O arrematante ficará no direito do nu proprietário,
ou seja, o arrematante só poderá entrar na
posse do imóvel quando o uso fruto acabar.
Então veja, você como arrematante, se você arrematar
um imóvel que tem essa condição de nua
propriedade, você vai ser o proprietário daquele imóvel,
mas você só pode entrar na posse daquele
imóvel, você só poderá fazer o que você
quiser com aquele imóvel quando o uso fruto
acabar.
No nosso exemplo aqui, você arrematou esse imóvel
e ficou no lugar desse filho que era
o nu proprietário.
Você vai ter que esperar a morte desse
casal acontecer para que você possa entrar na
posse daquele bem, porque no nosso caso o
uso fruto é vitalício.
Então é vitalício, só vai extinguir o uso
fruto com a morte desse casal.
Então você como proprietário teria que esperar a
morte desse casal.
O que eu acho desses casos?
Eu não participo, nunca participei, porque a maioria
dos casos de uso fruto são vitalícios.
Então você vai ter que esperar a morte
de uma pessoa para que você tenha posse
sobre aquele bem, para que você possa fazer
o que você quiser.
Além de ter leilão como uma finalidade de
investimento, de trabalhar com pessoas que têm essa
finalidade de investimento, que buscam leilão e investimento,
não seria interessante esperar o prazo de uma
morte de uma pessoa que ninguém sabe em
quanto tempo vai acontecer.
Não tem como prever isso.
E também tem o detalhe que eu não
quero participar de um negócio em que para
eu ser completamente feliz naquele negócio, eu tenho
que esperar a morte de alguém.
Isso por si só já é um fator
que me afasta desse tipo de leilão.
Mas cabe a você analisar se você quer
ou não participar.
De repente você vê um leilão de nua
propriedade e você vai constatar que aquelas pessoas
que têm o uso fruto vitalício, que usam
os usufrutuários, eles têm 99 anos.
Pode ser que você ache que vale a
pena participar daquele leilão e esperar aquelas pessoas
morrerem.
Eu particularmente não gosto.
Agora uma observação também.
Eu falei que o uso fruto pode ser
temporário ou vitalício.
Se ele for temporário e faltar pouco tempo
para ele acabar, pode ser que valha a
pena você participar dele.
Vamos supor, era um uso fruto de 3
anos.
Com 2 anos e 6 meses, aquele imóvel
vai a leilão.
Pode ser que você, como arrematante, ache interessante
esperar aqueles 6 meses que você acredite que
o desconto que está sendo aplicado ali naquele
leilão é tão vantajoso que você espera tranquilamente
acabar aqueles 6 meses para o uso fruto
se extinguir.
Então fica a seu critério de saber o
que você vai fazer ou não.
A consequência é sempre que você vai ter
que esperar o uso fruto acabar.
Se ele for temporário, você vai ter que
esperar o final do tempo pelo qual o
uso fruto foi constituído.
Se ele for vitalício, você vai ter que
esperar a morte dos usufrutuários para poder tomar
posse.
Eu coloquei aqui um exemplo bem clássico disso
que eu falei, que primeiro existe uma doação
e depois existe o uso fruto vitalício.
Então está lá.
Registro 8, de 23 de abril de 2014.
A data da escritura, o nome dos proprietários,
Laerte e Janette, transmitiram o título de doação
para os seus filhos, Jorge, Cristiane e Fabiane.
E logo após, vem o registro 9, que
é realmente fazendo o uso fruto vitalício, que
diz que pela mesma escritura retrocitada, quer dizer,
citada no registro número 8, os doadores Laerte
e sua mulher Janette, já qualificados, reservaram para
si o uso fruto vitalício sobre o imóvel
objeto dessa macrícula.
Significa então que o Laerte e a Janette
vão usar o imóvel da forma que eles
preferirem, inclusive podendo alugar, até a morte deles.
Esse imóvel, esse exemplo aqui, é um exemplo
de um imóvel que está indo a leilão.
Eu não sei quantos anos tem o Laerte,
eu não sei quantos anos tem a Janette,
mas isso por si só seria um fator
para eu não participar, porque é um tempo
muito imprevisível e eu não gostaria de participar
de um negócio que seria para gerar lucro,
em que eu dependesse da morte de outra
pessoa.
Mas fica ao critério de cada um de
vocês analisar se vai ou não participar.